hello everybody my name is mark lard
welcome to foreign creature now if you
remember the visitor this game was
actually inspired by the visitor in that
it's a point-and-click style adventure
horror game with a lot of stuff going on
and you're supposed to what I'm guessing
is murder this poor old unsuspecting man
who doesn't know that he's about to die
in life ok so there's various things in
the environment that you can click and
this game was actually made a long time
ago kinda in the same vein as the
visitor was made a while ago back in the
golden era flash but if I do this in the
right order
it should oh oh just that easy then ok
so now what yeah I think oh oh oh God
oh and melted his head off well that's
good then I don't know how I did that do
I have telepathic powers poor old man
was just wearing his knight slippers
trying to have a good day at the office
probably going home to see his wife of
40 years and now he's gone for good
ok so what do I owe ahh oh I'm I'm much
stronger than I anticipated oh and I
have a lovely tongue oh this is a great
creature because the visitor was like an
alien worm from the sky so this one is
kind of so oh I do oh hey how's it going
buddy are you doing friend oh let me
guess it's your last day of retirement
you're about to go see your friends for
a drink oh you don't have a care in the
world do you okay so I'm hidden over
there ah okay
banana everyone's fate oh oh
come on is this really ah this is gonna
work probably huh
oh oh no don't do it oh he goofed oh
he's been goofed Oh God
ah
bang haha ow I mean I've seen videos of
people getting hit with hit with
fluorescent bulbs and no oh god no why
did I turn the light on oh oh that's so
bad I mean obviously it's bad
cold-blooded murder but you know let me
just state the obvious some more why did
I turn the light on with the gun okay so
what do I do now does he have like keys
or something or can I just leave yeah
there we go oh he's almost adorable you
know in a kind of murder II horrifying
way he's lovely so where am I going now
okay hang on a second here I want to
question the logic of that of the
security of putting the keys behind the
nameplate over the doctor
I mean I'm accepting of a lot of things
over no no oh no no not Fido oh the
sound effect is really boying
okay I don't feel it's bad anymore no I
feel Darb why is your chainsaw again the
security of putting the keys behind the
professor sign and then having a
chainsaw just lying about and having
this dumb dog barking at the hole in the
window instead of the actual threat can
that bird shut up hey Kitty house uh-huh
yeah y'all go play with your friend Oh
silly
haha oh man
well that didn't sound good am I
supposed to be doing Oh
jain's uh-oh oh god no oh god why am i
expecting things to be any less good yes
please thank you oh how did that happen
that was cool what did I do
did I inject my soul into the bird oh
this is so bizarre why did I need the
chainsaw to finish off the dog that's
just horrible okay now to go infect a
human
I couldn't have just infected the doctor
no he wasn't in good enough shape I
guess neither was the security guard oh
hello oh god it's an unsuspecting happy
family what am i oh okay uh-huh uh-huh
oh no it's a loving husband and wife I'm
just here to destroy everything sploosh
Oh oh she's dead oh that poor husband he
knows something's going wrong but he's
too afraid just hoping it's awaking name
oh oh oh God well this is me now I guess
sooo so what do I do about that
am I like what do i click on I have no
idea anymore help uh-oh
well that was barely Oh oh no oh no I
don't wanna oh I did it why it's so sad
she was probably already electrocuted oh
no oh no oh what is okay well after work
I was just an alien that wanted to be a
normal person so bad that I'm uh oh yeah
yeah now that I got this body nothing
will stand in my way yeah well it's good
morning wife how are you there's more oh
god of course
glad this guy had a trenchcoat so handy
and a facemask
he's very afraid of germs he should have
been a little more afraid of aliens -
hey hey oh god that's so weird
so now what how did he go from a
creature in a lab to fully fleshed human
ready to invade the world I'm not
entirely sure about the logic of his
actions I'm if he's here if he just
wanted freedom then why did he need to
be a human i imagine that he's going
somewhere important and he's dead oh
okay still going oh I thought that was
gonna be like the end of it why do I
need to go on a murderous rampage more I
really got some get in the mindset of
this guy yeah yeah I'm an alien creature
I need to murder everyone I can maybe
upgrade into a better human body this
one's kind of not strong at all should
have gotten in that security yard he
would have been a lot better all right
what do I do now do you have a fish on
the line well I'm just thinking very
loudly to myself no one be bothered by
the screaming guy in a red car out of
nowhere
hey hey I'm gonna kill all these guys
azuz I figure out where the hell to do
yeah oh that rock that run that was so
difficult for her rival rival rival yes
fight humans no it's okay honey
no he's a rocking me I can't stand for
that kill him No shut up up ah I guess
this is my voice now okay I'm gonna stop
this knife of course oh I didn't do that
oh I infected his brain somehow don't
ask me how yeah lady just stay there
okay
Jesus that's horrible
Oh God oh that's not good oh they're
just gonna be looping back and forth
lady run out of the park don't just keep
running you're not trapped in here you
might be psychotic and crazy but you can
leave
all right I guess snake
okay snake sure snake yeah yeah okay oh
why there's no logical reason behind it
all
just sheer murderous madness and I do
not approve of sheer murderous madness
was that ah why do you still trying to
capture the reasoning mind all this do
you wanted to stay oh and now I'm gonna
mix them all together and create a
superhuman one human not good enough I'm
gonna mash them all into okay really I'm
just gonna make human soup oh and then I
Drive up right okay
I just wanted to wreck their day on the
real douchebag I'm just here to cause as
much chaos as possible
oh okay
haha all in a day's work yeah yeah now I
can get out of here no one's is vex a
thing no one would suspect a guy with
Teleca no you're smiling oh you you're
just a lovable doof to the end wait
professor Douglas isn't that the same
book yeah
oh god yeah I forgot you had those from
behind the sign why are you going back
yeah why are we back are you trying to
figure out how you were made oh hi wait
is that Professor Douglas who the hell
is that and why do I care and why is any
of this a thing okay
ah he doesn't suspect a thing he doesn't
respect his imminent demise haha oh wait
what am I doing with this kind of like
what am i what am i do ah the music's
getting so intense oh here we go
what is that what is that what is that
thermos water bottle hey you
Oh
okay how do you explain that how do you
explain any of that you have telekinesis
you could have just ripped his head off
I guess I wouldn't have been artistic
enough you I've got class in style oh
he's looking up how he is ah
it has been seven days since I recover
the foreign specimen in the field near
my laboratory it was some sort of alien
like creature in the shape of an embryo
contained within a small media my
curiosity as a science took over
scientists took over as I immediately
took it into my job it was indeed an
amazing discovery week past one thing
for sure specimen possesses amazing rate
of growth I don't think I would take the
chance now seeing erratic behavior it's
a shame I might have to kill the
specimen tomorrow to safely proceed with
the research there's too much
uncertainty involved I can't take
further risk
ah oh hi who are you uh uh Oh God
Oh No wait a minute huh
Oh God what's happening why I don't get
it what's going on oh man
I'm reliving all my horrible memories oh
hi how's it goin friend oh you look good
okay I get sexy in the foreign creature
now I know there's a sequel so let me
know let me know if you guys want me to
play the second one that was really
interesting I gotta admit like obviously
these point click style games all kind
of have a similar theme going through
them but this one was interesting
because I'm very curious like what's the
motivation who's this horrible rampaging
monster that he just wants to
continually murder besides just being a
horrible murderous rampaging monster so
bad
you everybody so much for watching and
as always see in the next video why are
you lonely - a prisoner that you don't
know you literally have